[Música]
4 millones y medio de personas estarían
Privadas del servicio eléctrico en
Ucrania como consecuencia de los ataques
de Moscú entre tanto el ejército de kiev
sigue acumulando Arsenal militar que
Rusia Deja atrás en su retirada
Guillermo lasso extiende el estado de
excepción a la provincia de Santo
Domingo de los tsáchilas que se une a
las provincias de esmeraldas y de guayas
esto luego de la violencia desatada por
bandas de narcotráfico debido a la
política gubernamental de traslado de
preso analizamos
a unos días de las elecciones de medio
término en Estados Unidos seguimos con
nuestros reportajes especiales para
intentar entender cuál es la situación
que viven los norteamericanos que se
irán a las urnas el próximo 8 de
noviembre
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 Mi nombre es Rodrigo sedano y
es un gusto acompañarlos abrimos en
Ucrania el presidente bolodimir celenski
asegura que por lo menos 4 millones y
medio de personas permanecen
temporalmente sin electricidad debido a
los constantes ataques rusos a
infraestructuras energéticas Rusia ha
reivindicado esta estrategia militar
contra las plantas de Ucrania mientras
avanzan las evacuaciones de civiles por
parte de autoridades prorusas engerson y
mientras Ucrania sigue recibiendo
grandes cantidades de ayuda monetaria y
militar las tropas de kiev se están
encontrando con numerosos equipos
militares de alta operatividad que los
rusos dejan en su vida ante la
contraofensiva ucraniana unas armas
Alemania no duda en utilizar en combate
Rafael Pérez nos cuenta más
como regalos rusos para las fuerzas
ucranianas en la psiquiadas ciudad de
los disparos de las tropas de kiev
tienen un sello de precisión enemiga
varios tanques utilizados en la defensa
de esa urbe hacen parte del armamento
ruso que ha sido capturado por el
ejército local
es poderoso esta pieza armamento nos ha
sido regalada por los rusos se llama
nona de cbk es beca tiene alta muy alta
precisión y ahora funciona en su contra
nos ayuda a alejarlos Y es que ante el
avance de las tropas ucranianas las
fuerzas rusas huyen dejando atrás
importantes piezas de uso militar en
particular estos tanques de fabricación
rusa fueron capturados a principio de
año y fueron reacondicionados por los
ucranianos según el diario de Wall
Street journal el número de tanques y
vehículos que se les retira la z
característica y se les reacondiciona
para el uso de Ucrania es considerable
hasta principio de octubre se
contabilizan unos 421 tanques 192
vehículos blindados Y al menos 44
lanzadores múltiples de cohetes la
situación en ese enclave de tamiesk es
compleja pero al parecer las nuevas
adquisiciones cumplen con su función
hubo muchos disparos antes bombardeos de
su lado y de nuestro lado Ahora hay
menos bombardeos de su lado y también
estamos disparando menos en las últimas
semanas las tropas ucranianas
desarrollan una contraofensiva bagmut es
un enclave importante para las fuerzas
rusas que progresan lentamente a través
de Daniel apoyados por el grupo
paramilitar Wagner una leve mejora en
esa zona para Moscú desde la toma de la
ciudad desde chance y se dieron a mitad
de año
en el marco de la Cumbre del g7 de
Alemania el secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos Anthony blinken habló
sobre el consenso de este grupo de
países sobre la necesidad de alinear su
enfoque con china además anunció que se
ha acordado crear un nuevo grupo de
coordinación para ayudar a preparar
restaurar y defender la red energética
de Ucrania
como ha hecho el g7 en cada paso estamos
abordando juntos las últimas escaladas
de Rusia y manteniéndonos firmes con
Ucrania en infraestructura el g7 acordó
crear un nuevo grupo de coordinación
para ayudar a reparar a restaurar y
defender la red energética de Ucrania la
red misma que el presidente Putin está
brutalizando y estamos enfocando más
nuestro apoyo de seguridad en ayudar a
Ucrania a protegerse contra estos
ataques fortalecer las defensas aéreas y
aumentar la producción de defensa
este viernes es la ex Primer Ministro
pakistaní Irán kang habló desde el
hospital donde está recibiendo
tratamiento tras haber sido disparado en
una pierna Desde allí describió Cómo
varios hombres intentaron matarlo en el
ataque que sufrió el jueves el ex Primer
Ministro acusó sin presentar pruebas a
miembros del actual gobierno de haber
conspirado para acabar con su vida
Gabriel colsén nos cuenta más
lanzando acusaciones desde el hospital
el ex Primer Ministro Pakistán y brancan
habló por primera vez desde el atentado
que sufrió el jueves en un mitching
contó lo ocurrido durante al ataque y
señaló como responsables a varios
miembros del actual gobierno de haber
intentado matarlo nombró específicamente
al Primer Ministro ses basarif al
ministro del interior ranas anaula y los
servicios de inteligencia pero no aportó
pruebas
en primer lugar rana sanaula Por qué
ranas anaula hizo el plan porque ranas
anaula es un asesino rana sanaula y se
va a salir
los dos funcionarios rechazaron las
acusaciones y pidieron una investigación
independiente sobre el tiroteo y brancan
llevaba una semana encabezando marchas
para obtener la organización de
elecciones anticipadas el jueves en una
de ellas en guajirabat un individuo le
disparó
a la pierna en total el atentado dejó un
muerto y al menos 10 heridos cuando
estaba en el contenedor de repente hubo
una Ráfaga de balas las balas me dieron
en la pierna y me caí este viernes sus
partidarios organizaron protestas en
todo el país bloquearon carreteras y se
enfrentaron a las fuerzas de seguridad
una agenda conseguir una fecha para las
elecciones y celebrarlas la marcha real
continuará hasta que se dé la hora y la
fecha de las elecciones el atentado
aumentó aún más las tensiones del país
sumido en una profunda crisis política
desde que Khan fue expulsado del poder
tras una moción de censura en el
congreso y posteriormente
descalificado por la comisión electoral
Para ocupar cargos públicos durante 5
años
seguimos en Ecuador el gobierno de
Guillermo lasso anunció la extensión del
estado de excepción a la provincia de
Santo Domingo de los tsáchilas una
decisión que tomó el martes para las
regiones de esmeraldas y guayas esto a
consecuencia de la ola de violencia
desatada en el país por bandas de
narcotraficantes como reacción al
traslado de presos el jueves el ejército
recuperó el control de la cárcel de
Guayaquil principal foco de la violencia
para ampliar la noticia hablamos con el
abogado especialista en temas
penitenciarios Santiago Argüello señor
Argüello bienvenida franch 24 que ha
cambiado en Ecuador para que ahora los
grupos criminales tengan la fuerza de
retar al poder del estado
Muchas gracias Te hago
una observación inmediata porque me
parece que ha habido un cierto
reduccionismo en la interpretación de
los fenómenos que están sucediendo en mi
país es lamentable lo que estamos
viviendo Pero hay que hacer un esfuerzo
de interpretación que no es
exclusivamente el poder de los
narcotraficantes hay una serie de
elementos que tienen que ver con la
realidad social y humana del país antes
regresamos a ver a Colombia para saber
lo que estaba pasando con el conflicto
social y armado pero ahora tenemos que
mirar hacia adentro y tenemos que
reconocer que que en el Ecuador Se ha
producido una espiral de violencia y de
que se ha vuelto una cosa usual esto
porque estamos con 2021 a 22 muertos
cada fin de semana en Guayaquil Y eso
significa que las cosas
fueron de las manos eso es un escenario
absolutamente grave no solo al interior
de las prisiones sino también fuera de
ellas y Porque creo Usted que
se ha acrecentado está esperar de
violencia en el país y que está
planteando el gobierno para frenarla
la
delincuencia en general tiene procesos
de aprendizaje
en los cuales la sociedad va cambiando y
va cuando hablábamos hace un Hace unos
días con alguien con quien habíamos
vivido la infancia pensábamos que en
esta ciudad había había un solo el
seguimiento de una sola suerte de un
solo Crimen y ahora Estamos viendo este
eclosión criminal que sí que tiene que
ver ya con con cierto grado de
terrorismo hay cosas que que se nos han
ido de las manos y por eso Nosotros
hemos estado siempre siempre tratando de
mirar el conjunto desde la perspectiva
mía que es de la doctrinólogo
yo estimo que hay que profundizar sobre
las cosas que están pasando en el país
por ejemplo no tenemos un estudio serio
sobre sobre los los jóvenes
Qué es lo que está pasando con la
juventud en nuestro país y esa pregunta
sigue siendo vigente Porque muchos no no
solo los los sicarios sino también las
víctimas son muchachos jóvenes y
entonces tenemos que plantearnos los
problemas para empezar a a buscar una
respuesta la respuesta no es la que ha
dado el gobierno hoy porque estamos
pensando simplemente en una reubicación
de ciertos detenidos de un pabellón en
otro pero tenemos ciudades carcelarias
yo no sé si en Colombia Existe alguna
que haya tenido
17.500 presos eso es lo que está pasando
en Guayaquil no hay tampoco
la reflexión de política pública en
en esas ciudades donde se han
concentrado los centros carcelarios no
hay el sentido de un régimen mínimo de
separación en que unas cárceles sean
metros de cumplimiento de pena y otras
tengan que ver con la detención
preventiva entonces todas esas cosas
están colaborando entonces diga los
malos gobiernos y la corrupción que
también siembran de mal ejemplo a la
sociedad ecuatoriana Sí señor Argüello
Muchas gracias por ampliarnos toda esta
información
Gracias a ti gracias cambiamos de tema
porque medios estadounidenses afirman
que el ex presidente Donald Trump planea
anunciar el próximo 14 de noviembre su
candidatura a la elección presidencial
de 2024 El ex mandatario jamás reconoció
su derrota ante el demócrata Joe biden Y
ayer Durante los actos de campaña de
Cara a las elecciones de medio término
del próximo martes aseguró que muy
probablemente buscaría volver a la Casa
Blanca
Y a lo largo de esta semana los llevamos
a través del corazón de Estados Unidos
para conocer más de cerca los temas que
se decidirán en las elecciones de medio
término del 8 de noviembre y uno de
ellos es la crisis climática hoy Vamos
hasta Nueva Orleans en Luisiana
construida sobre tierras pantanosas hace
unos 300 años es una de las ciudades de
Estados Unidos más vulnerables a los
impactos del cambio climático allí los
expertos advierten que si las
temperaturas siguen incrementándose el
aumento del nivel del mar inundará gran
parte de la costa de Luisiana en las
próximas décadas
fundada por colonos franceses hace más
de 300 años Nueva Orleans está amenazada
por fenómenos meteorológicos extremos
para protegerse de Los Huracanes la
ciudad invirtió 14.500 millones de
dólares en un nuevo sistema de diques
claro no es un sistema 100% Perfecto es
un sistema de reducción de riesgos el
cambio climático hace que todos los
lugares del sur de Luisiana sean
vulnerables la ciudad ahora Está rodeada
por un muro de 560 kilómetros de largo y
8 metros de alto el sistema sobrevivió a
su gran primera prueba en 2021 con el
huracán Aída
los diques necesitan mantenimiento
continuamente aquí se puede ver qué
parte del muro contra inundaciones se
está hundiendo esta pieza y esta pieza
estaban niveladas y ahora tenemos
probablemente alrededor de 5 centímetros
de desplazamiento
Los Huracanes no son la única amenaza
toda la costa de Luisiana también se
enfrenta un aumento del nivel del y los
expertos adviertan que podría subir 60
centímetros para 2050
Si tuvieras que mirar hacia el agua de
allí verás que hay un montón de árboles
muertos esto una vez fue un bosque de
ciprés
y habría proporcionado un amortiguador
natural para Nueva Orleans de las
tormentas Los huracanes y el agua
para hacer frente a la creciente amenaza
empresarios locales están tratando de
encontrar soluciones esta empresa
recicla vidrio de la ciudad para
convertirlo en Arena con la esperanza de
frenar la erosión de la costa
traemos unas 15 toneladas de vidrio a la
semana todo lo que se tritura cae en un
embudo el material pesado cae
directamente al fondo de esta bolsa de
aquí Este es nuestro principal producto
luego la arena se transfiere a sacos de
tela que se descomponen en seis meses lo
que permite que el nuevo material se
mezcle con el medio ambiente
aquí se han reciclado hasta ahora 1250
toneladas de vidrio
el estado de un campo de fútbol cada 100
minutos no podemos reemplazar eso pero
podemos implementar estratégicamente
nuestro material para frenar la erosión
tres veces por semana los residentes
vienen a dejar sus botellas de vidrio
cuánto impacto tienen 18.000 kilos
depende del escenario si está bien
desplegado 4.500 kilos de arena pueden
cambiar la trayectoria de un pantano
la restauración costera ha sido algo por
lo que peleamos en Luisiana toda mi vida
he discutido al respecto Entonces cuando
lo ves desaparecer de primera mano es
como un shock estos muchachos pelean esa
batalla la forma en que peleó esa
batalla extrayendo más vasos el 8 de
noviembre los votantes de Luisiana y de
todo el país emitirán sus votos si bien
aproximadamente la mitad de ellos dice
que el cambio climático es importante
está muy por detrás de otros temas como
la al derecho al aborto o el crimen
hasta aquí las noticias llegan
conectados
[Música]